[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle édition de senna 360
voici les titres edouard philippe
renouent le dialogue avec les
collectivités après une période de
tension le premier ministre a promis que
les concours financiers de l'état ne
baisseront pas en 2018
en ouverture de la conférence des villes
qui se tient aujourd'hui à la mairie de
paris nous serons en direct dans un
instant à quatre jours des élections
sénatoriales la suite de notre série
consacrée à la campagne vu du terrain
reportage dans les hauts-de-seine un des
départements que la droite entend bien
conserver malgré vous allez le voir une
multiplication des candidatures
dissidentes
comment rendre le travail parlementaire
plus efficace
françois de rugy le président de
l'assemblée nationale veut réformer
l'institution et ses méthodes de travail
pour dit il légiférer plus vite
est ce réellement possible quels impacts
au sénat on en débat dans ces nains 360
et je vous rappelle que vous pouvez
réagir à nos débats sur twitter avec le
hashtag à senna 360 pour m'accompagner
cet après midi sa verrière ogec et
mickaël szames s en direct de l'hôtel de
ville le multiplex s'est tout de suite
calmer la grogne des élus renouer le
dialogue avant les sénatoriales voilà à
quoi s'est attelée edouard philippe
devant la conférence des villes organisé
par l'association france urbaine
le premier ministre a abordé sans tabou
tous les sujets qui fâchent des contrats
aidés à la taxe d'habitation sans
oublier la baisse des dotations quentin
quel messi opération déminage pour le
premier ministre ce matin en ouverture
de la conférence des villes qui réunit
les 2000 agglomération métropole et
grandes villes de france
edouard philippe est immédiatement
revenu sur le dossier chaud du moment
la baisse des dotations de l'état il ne
s'agit pas de 13 milliards d'euros de
baisses de la dépense locale
nous vous demandons de maîtriser votre
dépenses y compris votre dépense
tendanciel qui est en hausse c'est très
différent
vos dépenses vont continuer à progresser
mais vous devez infléchir la courbe pour
les maires présents ce matin à la
conférence des villes on note
l'évolution dans la méthode de
l'exécutif après plusieurs annonces très
mal perçues par les élus locaux sur les
dotations les emplois aidés ou encore la
taxe d'habitation
aujourd'hui ces édiles veulent croire à
une nouvelle dynamique
on ne voulait pas que ce soit un coup de
rabot brutale tout de suite il a adopté
semble t il une méthode que l'ont
appelée de nos voeux qui tient compte de
la croissance de la diversité de nos
territoires et qui donc va nous
permettre de respirer pour d'autres élus
notamment à gauche rien à faire le début
de quinquennat est raté pour ce qui est
des relations avec les collectivités
territoriales
nous sommes porteurs de cette grogne
parce qu elle nous vient du terrain le
premier ministre a dit que les mères
c'était vraiment l'incarnation de la
proximité et du terrain et bah oui et ce
qui remonte du terrain
c'est un profond mécontentement le
sentiment qu'après la conférence
nationale du territoire et il y a eu de
tromperie puisque toute une série de
tuiles lors sans tomber sur la tête
pendant l'été des élus qui vont être
très attentif lors de la présentation du
projet de loi de finances mi octobre
déjà les associations des maires de
france des départements et des régions
ont annoncé vouloir maintenir la
pression lors de leur congrès réunies
dans les prochaines semaines et on va
tout de suite retrouvé mes kms en direct
de l'hôtel de ville de paris bonjour aux
micaëla lorsque le premier ministre a
réussi à renouer le dialogue avec les
collectivités territoriales après un été
meurtrier
car il n'y avait pas de grandes
déclarations d'amour ce qu'on voulait
ici tout cas pour les grands élus
s'étaient des preuves d'amour le premier
ministre est donc venu avec certaines
annonces pas moins de cinq ministres
aussi sont venus c'est parce que noël
avant l'heure finalement pour les
collectivités il ya et chacun est venu
avec un petit cadeau notamment le
premier ministre qui a formulé une
demande d'or veloppe supplémentaire pour
les collectivités pas loin de 384
millions seront alloués à ces
collectivités autre exemple très concret
et gérald darmanin un ministre des
comptes publics est venu annoncer que
d'un reportage sur la tva d'un point
serait accordée également pour les
collectivités locales c'était une
annonce qui avait été faite par le
dernier quinquennat peut-être qu'elles
ne devaient pas continuer pour ce
quinquennat ici et finalement
et bien c'est une confirmation un point
de tva égale 97 millions d'euros nous
disait tout à l'heure
le ministre des comptes publics tout à
l'heure dans le couloir ici à l'hôtel de
ville ce qui représente très exactement
la somme de 481 millions d'euros
accordés aujourd'hui pour les
collectivités locales certains diraient
que c'est une goutte d'eau par rapport
aux 13 millions 13 milliards notamment
qu a abordé le premier ministre matin
mais ça reste quand même un geste très
important il fallait donc calmer la
grogne
on comprend bien une forme de rattrapage
après un été difficile françois baroin
disait ce matin que c'était un été
meurtrier à laon le dialogue
willy renou il va y avoir maintenant une
vigilance de la part des élus locaux
être très vigilants par rapport au
projet de loi de finances qui sera
abordé dans les prochaines semaines au
parlement
et puis évidemment il y aura des congrès
mais surtout ici ce que l'on voit c'est
qu'il ya des élections sénatoriales qui
approche et tout le monde se dit en tout
cas les ministres qui on a pu rencontrer
se disent notamment et gérald darmanin
qui en a discuté tout à l'heure nous
disent eh bien que peut-être à partir de
lundi après les élections sénatoriales
la grogne se calmera un petit peu
merci beaucoup michael liles à metz pour
toutes ces précisions et autre thème sur
lequel le gouvernement doit rassurer il
s'agit du logement après l annonce de la
baisse des appels des mesures fiscales
choc ont été présenté ce matin en
conseil des ministres afin d'encourager
la cession de terrains à construire mais
aussi la prolongation du prêt à taux
zéro et du dispositif pinel assassine 6
ou construire plus
et vite voilà l'objectif du gouvernement
et pour cela il compte tout d'abord
libérer des terrains à construire ce de
l'état tout d'abord mais aussi ceux des
particuliers qui grâce à un abattement
fiscal allant de 100 % pour les
logements sociaux 85 % pour les
logements intermédiaires et 70 % pour
les logements libres vendrait plus
facilement leur terrain autres mesures
pour inciter à construire plus vite la
reconduction de deux aides publiques le
prêt à taux zéro et les avantages qui se
cale dit pinel qui seront désormais
réservés aux zones tendues enfin le
gouvernement prévoit de sanctionner des
recours abusifs contre les permis de
construire des recours qui ralentissent
les projets immobiliers
autre axe du plô logement aidé les
jeunes avec deux mesures phares la
construction d'ici cinq ans de 60 mille
logements étudiants et 20 mille
logements pour les jeunes actifs et la
création d'un bail mobilité pouvant
aller de 1 à 10 mois où il n'y aura pas
besoin de déposer de garanties
personnelles auprès des propriétaires
enfin le gouvernement souhaite revoir le
mode de calcul des apl
elle se baseront désormais sur le revenu
en cours et non sur le revenu engrangé
deux ans auparavant
et pour plus de précision je vous
propose d'écouter les réactions du
ministre jacques mézard il était au
micro de mickaël isabey s'il ya quelques
minutes le ministre vous venez de dire
que la porte était ouverte finalement
pour le dialogue encore sur le texte que
vous allez présenter sur le logement
la porte est vraiment ouverte elle a
toujours été ouverte salle et le
dialogue je vais mène constamment depuis
le jour où je suis entré dans ce
ministère de la cohésion des territoires
je n'ai pas passé une seule journée
sans recevoir sans écouter sans
dialoguer et bien sûr le dialogue avec
les collectivités locales pour moi il a
toujours été essentielle je suis encore
un élu local
j'ai longtemps jusqu'il ya quelques
semaines président est une agglomération
et si je n'étais pas à l'écouté des élus
locaux et des territoires ce serait
vraiment à désespérer sur le fond de
votre projet de la mairie entendu
simplement depuis ce matin on sent quand
même une envie de la part du
gouvernement de tendre la main
une envie de dialogue c'est un
rattrapage par rapport à cet été un peu
difficile que vous avez connues écoutez
en ce qui me concerne la l'écouté la
main tendue elle a toujours été à
disposition des élus locaux je pense que
je ne pense pas en trouver beaucoup qui
pourrait indiquer que je n'ai pas été à
leur écoute
ensuite il faut ensemble trouver des
solutions à la fois bien sûr par rapport
aux projets qui sont les leurs par
rapport aussi à la nécessité de lutter
contre le déficit budgétaire qui est un
véritable problème pour la france mais
je pense que ce dialogue nous l'avons
enclenché dans le secteur qui est le
mien il sera continuée que ce soit au
niveau territorial ou au niveau de la
politique du logement il n'est pas
question d'interrompre ce dialogue
vous souhaitez une révolution en termes
de logement savoir que c'est la fin des
aides à la personne pour privilégier
quoi les aides à la pierre c'est une un
changement total du modèle social
français
non la question vous poser est
totalement inexact s'agit pas de d'aller
vers la fin des aides à la personne il
n'a jamais été question de cela
il s'agit de mieux gérer les aides de
l'état
il n'a jamais été question de supprimer
les aides à la personne
moi je voudrais une bonne fois pour
toutes qu'on écoute ce que l'on dit
qu'on ne soit pas d'accord c'est
possible mais je ne souhaite pas qu'on
caricature
nous avons des contraintes budgétaires
dans ce pays jusqu'ici on a répondu aux
questions posées par les français par
l'endettement
aujourd'hui nous savons les uns et les
autres que ce n'est plus possible donc
il ya un certain nombre d'économies qui
doivent être faites
nous cherchons le moyen de les faire de
la manière la plus judicieuse possible
de faire des restructurations
effectivement mais il n'a jamais été
question de supprimer par exemple lancé
d'appel vous avez bien compris
bien évidemment ma question sur les
appels il ya une levée de boucliers de
la personne personne n'a jamais dit
qu'on allait supprimer les apl cher
monsieur je trouve que cette réduction
cette schématisation et étape sera je
n'ai pas incroyable puisque votre
question a été posée mais je suis quand
même vous l'entendez mais moi je suis
obligé de vous dire les choses que l'on
essaie de faire en sorte que cela
fonctionne mieux et qu'il y a par
exemple au niveau du fonctionnement d'
écoutes qui sont considérables des
procédures qui sont inéquitables
quand on calcule les allocations sur les
revenus d'il ya deux ans et que en fait
ça un coot de plus d'un milliard par an
je pense pas que ça soit une bonne chose
quand il y a un coût de 600 millions
d'euros de fonctionnement je pense que
nous pouvons améliorer les choses
en tout cas il n'est pas dans les
intentions du gouvernement de diminuer
les allocations que reçoit chaque
allocataire je veut rectifier les choses
parce que cette formulation est
totalement non seulement réductrice mais
inexactes voilà pour la réaction de
jacques mézard au micro de michael à
metz autre réaction à présent celle de
la sénatrice corinne bouchoux elle est
au micro de salariat roseq qu'on drague
la salle des conférences est à vous
bonjour corine mauch au bonjour le
gouvernement mise donc sur une relance
de la construction pour faire baisser
les prix dans les zones tendues est ce
que c'est une bonne stratégie
écoutez c'est une idée je signerai
simplement que cette mesure à elle seule
ne suffira pas vous avez eu des
ministres précédemment
les ministres du flou causé pinel qui
doit déjà se sont attelés à ce problème
qui avait pris un certain nombre de
mesures et on s'aperçoit que le marché
de l'immobilier est à la fois un marché
complexe et où la question du prix n'est
pas exactement la même chose que le prix
des carottes donc c'est un peu y
participer ça peut ne pas être
automatique ça c'est l'économiste qui
vous dit ça mais que faut-il faire pour
lutter alors contre les loyers chers
c'est une des principales préoccupations
des français les difficultés à se loger
alors je pense qu'en france on a deux
problèmes et pas un seul
il ya effectivement le premier problème
dans les villes dans les agglomérations
et surtout les métropoles de
l'augmentation démentiel du prix des
loyers et donc là on a un problème
d'accessibilité et d'injustice d'accès
au logement où vous avez si vous voulez
pour parler simplement un effet
d'éviction les travailleurs les chômeurs
et les jeunes sont relégués et sont
éloignés des endroits où ils vivent et
d'où ils travaillent en revanche vous
avez un deuxième problème et j'aimerais
qu'on traite les deux en même temps
c'est un problème du mal logement
vous avez quand même plusieurs millions
de personnes qui sont à la rue fin des
milliers de personnes qui sont à la rue
et donc vous ne pouvez pas régler un
problème sans régler l'autre revenons-en
néanmoins aux annonces du gouvernement
ce choc de l'offre un don dont parle le
gouvernement est ce qu'il est possible
selon vous en ile de france
là justement où le retard dans la
construction est énorme
est-ce que ce choc de l'offre est
possible alors l'économiste vous dira
toujours qu'un choc de l'offre ne marche
pas toujours
la femme politique vous dira qu'un choc
de l'offre à lui seul je le répète n'est
pas suffisant vous pouvez créer des
logements
je vais vous prendre un exemple parlant
en espagne vous avez des dizaines de
milliers de logements qui sont vacants
vous pouvez regarder dans nos belles
régions avec un certain nombre de
dispositifs on a construit partout des
résidences avec de la défiscalisation ou
vous n'avez personne
donc le problème s'ils voulaient n'est
pas temps de construire plus de
logements en région parisienne
il est aussi de faire en sorte que nos
concitoyens aient les moyens économiques
d'habiter dans ces logements est ce que
cette politique de l'offre peut
néanmoins tirer les prix vers le bas
écoutez c'est pari que fait le
gouvernement cette politique
je ne suis pas marcheuse je ne vais pas
là désapprouvée par principe je dirai
que c'est une politique traditionnelle
ou sens qu'elle elle postule quand le
bâtiment va tout va
et donc c'est un signal symbolique que
l'on envoie au monde du btp et qui peut
être s'en contentera néanmoins je le
répète c'est bien construire des
logements
mais si vous avez une majorité de
français qui n'ont pas les moyens
d'accéder à ces logements
eh bien ça pose problème regardée
actuellement le parc social on a un parc
social
on a des logements vides ont compris en
région parisienne parce qu'un certain
nombre de nos concitoyens ou ne peuvent
pas y aller ou ne veulent pas y aller
alors vous êtes élu écologiste
que pensez-vous de la transformation du
crédit d'impôt pour la rénovation
énergétique en subventions l'idée est
bien c'est de rendre le dispositif
accessible à tous c'est pas une bonne
chose a coûté oui je pense que c'est une
mesure intelligente je vais m'expliquer
lorsque vous avez un crédit d'impôt ça
veut dire qu'on va retirer de ce que
vous auriez dû payer d'impôts une
certaine somme que l'on va vous rendre
donc ça avantage ceux qui payent déjà un
impôt en revanche ceux par exemple qui
ne payent pas d'impôts parce qu'ils ne
sont pas imposables non j'allais dire
aucune incitation à faire des travaux de
rénovation énergétique j'allais dire ils
ne gagnent pas grand chose puisque ils
peuvent ne pas être imposables donc
c'est une mesure qui est symboliquement
positive après je voudrais alerté sur un
point c'est aussi j'allais dire le
professionnalisme des entreprises
vous avez toutes sortes d'entreprises
des vertueuse des très compétente et
vous allez avoir et c'est peut-être le
risque un effet d'aubaine peut-être de
certaines entreprises qui vont se
tourner vers des publics qui auront le
problème de l' expertise et de faire
faire des travaux dans des bonnes
conditions donc j'allais dire il faut
être vigilant mais moi l'idée me
convient très bien merci beaucoup merci
corinne bouchoux d'avoir répondu à nos
questions merci merci merci à vous savez
rien pour cette réaction en direct dans
le reste de l'actualité à la veille
d'une nouvelle manifestation contre les
ordonnances
la petite phrase d'emmanuel macron
journaliste de cnn n'est sans doute pas
passé inaperçu auprès des syndicats le
chef de l'état a estimé que la
démocratie ce n'est pas la rue si je
respecte ceux qui manifestent je
respecte aussi les électeurs français et
ils ont voté pour le changement at il
expliqué marie vraiment nous prendrons
dorénavant la discipline à l'étranger de
ne pas parler de politique française
voilà une promesse qu emmanuel macron a
bien du mal à tenir il ya encore depuis
new york le président s'est laissé aller
à quelques confidences sur la réforme du
code du travail
j'ai expliqué ses réformes j'ai présenté
ses réformes pendant des semaines et des
semaines et j'ai été élu pour ses
réformes
je crois en la démocratie la démocratie
ce n'est pas la rue du côté de la
majorité
le message est pas si il faut clore au
plus vite le dossier loi travail
là il y a une preuve un processus qui a
été enclenché qui a été annoncé avant
l'élection présidentielle avant les
élections législatives en toute
transparence
réformer le code du travail par voie
d'ordonnancé nous en avons débattu à
l'assemblée avant au mois de juillet il
y a eu 35 heures deuxième mi-temps sa
botte
il a on vous entendre elle est
réellement une ratification car
l'exécutif doit faire face à des
mouvements de protestation dans la rue
la semaine dernière tout d'abord
mouvement de grève demain également
et ce samedi à l'appel du leader de la
france insoumise dans la ligne de mire
des manifestants
la loi travail présenté par les
syndicats et l'opposition comme une
catastrophe sociale
le bras de fer s'intensifie donc entre
un président qui veut incarner
l'autorité de l'état et des opposants
qui compte bien le faire céder
on va à présent notre page spéciale
consacrée aux élections sénatoriales
à quatre jours du scrutin le parti
socialiste pourrait profiter de
l'effondrement de la république en
marche et entend bien rester le second
groupe parlementaire à l'issue du
renouvellement
je vous propose d'écouter le
porte-parole du ps rachété mal qui se
veut optimiste
nous avons des socialistes combatif sur
le terrain des élus qui sont dans
l'opposition une opposition intelligente
au pouvoir je les dis notamment sur les
questions de lutte contre la casse
sociale et lutte contre la la casse
territoriales et qui vont ensuite porté
au sénat nos valeurs en lien avec le
parti socialiste parce que il ya encore
beaucoup de combats
je prends un exemple la question 2 du
projet de loi de finances 2010 8 ou au
delà des gesticulations du vieux pré
ministre c'est l'épreuve de vérité
et quand on nous annonce déjà une baisse
draps
tic du budget du logement et du budget
de l'emploi on ne peut que voir que ce
gouvernement à bien une politique de
droite et que les classes populaires les
classes moyennes et les collectivités
sont les grandes victimes de ce début de
quinquennat conférence au sénat avec
vous sa verrière ogec pour une nouvelle
réaction l'actualité politique ce jour
avec le sénateur socialiste du doubs
martial bourquin
bonjour martial bourquin
on le disait l'instant on voit plus que
quelques jours avant les sénatoriales et
vous me disiez ce sont les derniers
jours les plus décisifs
quel regard portez-vous sur l'avenir de
votre groupe du groupe ps au sénat
beaucoup parlent on parle de plus en
plus d'une scission du groupe
à l'issue de ces sénatoriales tout
d'abord je pense que vu la politique
actuelle envers les collectivités
locales
je pense qu'on devrait avoir un groupe
socialiste plus importante que prévu on
sait très bien que le collège électoral
est fixé depuis les élections
municipales qui les favorable aux
républicains
mais aujourd'hui vu les décisions que
prend le prénom de la république et le
gouvernement envers les collectivités
je sens comme un mécontentement
extrêmement fort si bien qu'on devrait
se retrouver qu'un groupe socialiste
plus important parce que nous nous
opposons à s'épauler et le groupe se
sceller ce pourrait-il se scinder en
deux à l'issue de ces sénatoriales je ne
le souhaite pas
ce serait la pire des choses simplement
il va falloir clarifier la clarification
c'est quoi si on soutient le
gouvernement et le président de la
république
ben c'est pas la place du parti
socialiste parti suisse doit être un
parti à la fois d'opposition mais à
partie aussi de gouvernement capable
demain en cas d'échec qui devient de
plus en plus probable du président de la
république et du gouvernement capable de
gouverner et là je pense vraiment qu'il
ya cette clarification opéré peut pas
avoir un pied dedans un pied dehors faut
que le soyons un parti d'opposition
clairement savait par exemple la baisse
des apl
pour redonner 4 milliards aux plus
riches d'entre nous c'est pas sérieux et
sur des questions comme celle là faut
être présent et avoir des positions
extrêmement ferme et en revanche pas de
raz-de-marée visiblement pas de
raz-de-marée on marche au sénat je pense
que même on va s'apercevoir qu'il y aura
de grosses difficultés pour le parti
présidentiel qui présente quelques
listes dans plusieurs départements
et je pense que les difficultés
s'amoncellent
il y a un mais il y avait l'assemblée
générale des maires du doubs j'ai senti
comme un mécontentement d'une force
considérable et inévitablement le parti
présidentiel va va subir ce rejet
quelques mots maintenant martial
bourquin sur cette décision historique
là le principe a été acté la vente du
siège du parti socialiste de la rue de
solferino votre réaction ça a été
annoncé hier soir c'est à la fois un
choc mais il fallait s'y attendre
1 c'est ce siège il a accompagné tout
s'est fait dans ce siège depuis le parti
d'epinay
il a les grande victoire nous nous
retrouvions à solférino les victoires
des deux victoires présidentielles mais
aussi les victoires aux élections
territoriales
ça a été d'un chargé d'histoire ce lieu
mais en même temps vu la défaite
historique que nous avons eues
vous pouvez pas garder siège et c'est
oui plusieurs dirigeants du parti depuis
hier soir demande un vote un vote des
militants ou un vote au conseil national
sur cette décision
est ce que vous vous le souhaitez
faut-il voter sur la vente du siège où
je pense que la direction qui est en
place et capable de nous dire si
financièrement on peut tenir ou non ce
siège
si on ne peut pas le dire à quoi ça sert
de voter ça me ça m'embêterait beaucoup
que il va falloir donner traque de
maintenant quand il ya la loi travail
qu'on va pouvoir licencier les personnes
comme on veut quand il valoir plus de
précarité
est ce qu'il faut garder un siège et met
beaucoup de moyens dans wii ce qu'il
faut faire le travail de militant au
près
du peuple de france et ceux qui ont
besoin de nous et alors c'est cela le
choix et je pense que on va nous
présenter un dossier
et dans ce dossier il y aura la
possibilité ou non de garder sous le
ferry nos et je pense que la mise en
vente ne faisait guère de doute
très bien merci merci beaucoup merci
martial bourquin d'avoir répondu à nos
questions merci merci à vous merci à
vous savez rien on en vient à présent
aux enjeux politiques groupe par groupe
de ces élections sénatoriales pour en
parler j'accueille au thème traduit
bonjour tam aujourd'hui on va parler du
groupe et l'air car ce que ce scrutin
devrait a priori à leur est plutôt
favorable oui à première vue c'est un
mécanique les grands électeurs sont à
95% des conseillers municipaux qui ont
été élus en 2014 l'élection à l'époque
avait donné lieu à une vague bleue et
donc la majorité de droite doit sortir
renforcé je vous donne également
quelques chiffres je rappelle que le
groupe ait l'air compte aujourd'hui 142
sénateurs et que 53 d'entre eux sont
renouvelables ce qui fait un taux de 37
%
le groupe tablerait sur un gain de 15 à
18 sièges qu'ils feraient un groupe à
cent cinquante cinq cent soixante
sénateurs mais satam c'était avant
l'élection d' emmanuel macron et le
raz-de-marée de la république en marche
à l'assemblée nationale oui et les grues
le groupe ait l'air a eu chaud
effectivement avant l'été il craignait
que de nombreux maires ruraux non
encartés rallye les rangs de la
république en marche mais voilà c'était
il ya deux mois
alors entre la baisse de popularité des
manuels macron les annonces impopulaire
auprès des élus locaux le moral est donc
meilleur pour les républicains
aujourd'hui
reste que tout de même avec les
bouleversements politiques récents il y
à de nouveaux points de fragilité au
sein du groupe notamment si les heller
constructif sans vous aussi des
centristes qu'ils font aujourd'hui tous
partis de la majorité sénatoriale
manquent à l'appel
et puis plus classiquement les élèves
font face à de nombreuses listes
dissidentes interview là dessus ils sont
victimes de leur succès 1 comme le
groupe s'attend à de bons résultats cela
suscite des convoitises notamment dans
les départements urbains
par exemple dans les hauts-de-seine la
liste de roger karoutchi investi par les
élèves fait face à quatre listes
dissidentes et l'air enfin divers droite
ou encore dans le nord et bien il ya
également la lie
de marc philippe daubresse qui fait face
à quatre autres listes de droite
et puis il ya également donc cette
division qui pourrait donc faire perdre
des sièges jusqu'à donc une dizaine de
sièges nous dit on notez que sinon et
bien les nerfs sont des champions de la
dissidence organisée et cela pour
contourner la loi sur la parité
l'exemple canonique sur cette élection
c'est la manche ou deux sénateurs
sortants philippe bas et jean bizet se
font face sur deux listes différentes
car les nerfs ne peuvent espérer que
deux sièges dans la manche
or les deuxièmes places de ces listes
ont évidemment occupés par des femmes
on termine thème sur les personnalités
et l'eire qui pourraient faire leur
entrée au sénat
oui j'en ai parlé tout à l'heure et bien
marc philippe daubresse ancien ministre
de jacques chirac puis de nicolas
sarkozy ancien député devrait être élu
dans le nord
on peut également parler d' edouard
courtial dans l'oise lui aussi qui fut
secrétaire d'état président du conseil
départemental dans l'oise on peut enfin
parler de frédéric péchenard lui aussi
sarkozyste l'ancien premier flic de
france qui est troisième sur la liste de
pierre charon à paris en position
éligible
notez enfin que brice hortefeux ou
encore natacha bouchart sont présents
sur des listes mais en simple soutien
car à leur place ils ne peuvent pas être
élu merci beaucoup au talent pour toutes
vos précisions suite à présent de notre
série consacrée à la campagne pour ces
élections sénatoriales mais cette fois
vu du terrain
direction les hauts de seine ce
département de l'ouest francilien
n'échappe pas à la multiplication des
candidatures et notamment des
candidatures dissidentes c'est le cas à
droite c'est un reportage de sandra
cerqueira
l'institution prévoit différents élus le
sénat seul contre-pouvoir à emmanuel
macron c'est le message délivré par
gérard larcher en personne venu soutenir
la liste officielle de la droite dans
les hauts-de-seine
emmenés par roger karoutchi sénateur
sortant dans le département la droite
par plus que divisée avec cinq listes
des dissidents ce qui pourrait coûter
cher
c'est bien qu'on se retrouve
dans le groupe des républicains au sénat
si on perd un siège ici un siège à paris
un siège en val d'oise un siège en seine
et marne un siège dans leur fief dans le
pas de calais on peut finir pour avoir
de mauvaises surprises le 24e soit pour
la majorité sénatoriale
on arrive le dernier rend la balle les
trois dernières et puis ça s'est sûr
façon l'union à droite éric berdoati
maire de saint cloud depuis 12 ans la
refuser ce dissident et l'air ne se
reconnaissait pas dans la liste
officielle
le renouvellement c'est la seule façon
pour lui de tirer les enseignements de
la présidentielle j'espère qu'il y aura
une prise de conscience de ce qui s'est
passé dans les ppp mois de mai et
notamment que la famille politique dans
laquelle je suis aujourd'hui soit un peu
plus ouvertes un peu plus moderne qu'est
ce qu'elle mais parce qu'elle démontre
depuis quelque temps ses divisions
pourraient profiter à la liste udi du
sénateur sortant hervé marseille
d'autant que cette fois les centristes
partent unis l'important pour lui est de
conforter la majorité de droite et du
centre au sénat
il faut aussi éviter que le gouvernement
et le président de la république ne
dispose d'une majorité des trois
cinquièmes pour faire passer des textes
constitutionnels et pas souhaitable que
le gouvernement dispose à la fois d'une
très large majorité à l'assemblée est
des trois cinquièmes au parlement il
faut qu'ils tiennent compte des
parlementaires sur la liste d' andré
gattolin on trouve des candidats de tous
bords et l'air udi ps le sénateur
sortant passé d'europe écologie est en
marche
combes sauvé son siège en piochant des
voix un peu partout mais la colère des
élus suite aux annonces du gouvernement
pèse sur sa campagne genre face à face
soir à 2 à 3 puis maintenant à s'agréger
andré gattolin dit ne pas avoir le choix
il se doit d'être offensif avec un
maître mot la pédagogie c'est mon rôle
de candidat c'est aussi en tant que
parlementaire c'est je peux soutenir un
gouvernement mais en même temps dire
voilà il ya telle chose qui ne va pas je
pense que on était trop brutal sur les
emplois aidés
bien sûr que voir simplement la
rentabilité ou la durabilité économique
c'est oublier qu'à une dimension sociale
il faut faire comme disent les
américains du fign keuning il faut faire
de l'ajustement soupe coincés pendant
des semaines le candidat ps dit avoir
appelé à l'union
mais la gauche part elle aussi divisée
avec trois listes
xavier iacovelli sait que la bataille
sera difficile nous avons perdu nos
communes nous avons perdu la plupart de
nos conseils départementaux
puisqu'on nous n'avons que deux malgré
tout nous sommes la première force
politique de gauche
et ça je pense que nos partenaires
avaient peut-être du mal à le concevoir
de se mettre derrière une force
politique qui avait n'avait plus de
mairie
mais malgré tout était la première force
en nombre de lieux dans les hauts de
seine
onze listes se disputent 7 sièges et la
droite largement favorite malgré ses
divisions pourraient rafler la mise
voilà et pour être tout à fait complet
sur ces sénatoriales dans les
hauts-de-seine
vous voyez la liste de tous à les
candidats qui s'affiche sur votre écran
sandra fer qui rament à rejoindre sur ce
plateau sandra vous avez donc et bien
été dans les hauts-de-seine pour voir
les enjeux de ces élections sénatoriales
il ya beaucoup de dissidences à droite
c'est le cas au niveau national mais là
quelle est la spécificité de ce
département
alors on peut déjà commencer par dire
que des dissidences cela n'a rien de
nouveau
les élus avoue même que les dissidents
c'est un peu comme une tradition
notamment à droite alors dans les
hauts-de-seine
on peut
on peut dire que les législatives ont
quelque peu bousculé le paysage
politique
lrm donc la république en marche a
obtenu dix députés alors que la droite
n'a conservé que deux ce qui a quand
même bouger les lignes et cela a donné
des envies aux perdants pour qui les
sénatoriales était une occasion de
s'offrir une deuxième chance donc parmi
les quatre têtes de listes dissidentes
de été candidat aux législatives donc
les maires eric berdoati et philippe
pemezec et il y avait aussi bernard
lepidi qui lui était candidat à
l'investiture des législatives et qui
est aussi candidat
maintenant aux sénatoriales en tant que
dissidents alors au delà de ça c'est
certainement le manque de leadership à
droite qui a favorisé les dissidences
roger karoutchi qui s'occupe des
investitures chez les républicains et
qui a suivi cela de très près dit bien
que c'était impossible de ramener tout
le monde à la maison car le parti est
tout simplement dans une phase
transitoire qu'il n'ya pas de président
et donc pas d'autorité naturelle
alors au final ces dissidences pourrait
faire perdre à la droite une dizaine de
sièges même si pas de quoi faire perdre
le sénat à la droite mais quelle
conséquence quelle résonance
c'est des finances dont elle avoir sur
le sénat alors c'est vrai que la
présidentielle a laissé des traces même
au sénat et le malaise est profond au
sein du groupe
lr à l'image de la crise que traverse le
parti on l'a évoqué juste avant et par
exemple eric berdoati que l'on voit dans
le reportage et qui est donc dissidents
divers droite lui ils dit vraiment est
clairement que s'il est élu il ne sait
pas s'il siégera au sein du groupe l'est
républicain il dit j'attends voir si le
groupe s'ouvre
si bruno retailleau et reconduit parce
que ce annoncé que bruno retailleau est
contestée par certains membres
il attend donc de voir et surtout le
regarde avec attention donc le possible
groupe les constructif qui
qui est en projet qui est voulu par
fabienne par fabienne keller
sauf que certains à droite comme au
centre pense que ce vent de fronde ne se
concrétisera pas quant au fils sont même
persuadés que gérard larcher est déjà à
la manoeuvre et qu'il est prêt à
rencontrer un à un ceux qui seraient
tentés de prendre leur envol et on
connaît les qualités de rassembleur de
gérard larcher et ils savent ils sont
persuadés qu'il sera ramenée ou plutôt
laissé à la maison donc ceux qui sont
tentés par les constructif pour
maintenir une majorité confortable
merci beaucoup faudra pour toutes vos
précisions
françois de rugy veut accélérer le
travail législatif le président de
l'assemblée nationale milite pour une
réduction du nombre de navettes
il l'a dit ce matin lors d'une
conférence de presse de rentrée alors
comment fonctionne aujourd'hui ce
travail au législatif entre les deux
assemblées est les explications de
fabien becker un an
c'est souvent le délai nécessaire entre
la rédaction d'une loi et sa
promulgation
trop long selon le président de
l'assemblée nationale ça pose un
problème démocratique pour nos
concitoyens nos concitoyens ne voir que
des propositions met autant de temps
ensuite à devenir réalité
prenons l'exemple d'un projet de loi
déposée au sénat par le gouvernement le
texte d'abord examiné et amendé par une
commission avant d'être débattu puis
voté par des sénateurs en séance
publique
il est alors transmis en l'état à
l'assemblée où reprend le même processus
d'examen modifications ou ajouts et vote
l'adoption définitive du texte implique
qu'il soit voté dans les mêmes termes
par les deux chambres
si elle ne tombe pas d'accord le texte
repart au sénat en deuxième lecture pour
être à nouveau amendé par les sénateurs
avant de revenir une nouvelle fois à
l'assemblée
on appelle ça la navette parlementaire
en cas de désaccord après deux lectures
une commission mixte paritaire composée
de députés et sénateurs tentent de
trouver un compromis
en cas d'échec c'est l'assemblée
nationale qui a le dernier mot
mais le gouvernement peut aussi engager
une procédure accélérée et réunir une
commission mixte paritaire après une
seule lecture dans chaque chambre
une méthode de plus en plus utilisé par
l'exécutif devant le congrès de
versailles cet été emmanuel macron avait
suggéré une simplification de la navette
afin d'accélérer la fabrique de la loi
un souci de lisibilité que partage le
président du sénat pour moi il faut
faire mieux la loi moderniser notre
manière d'être présent et puis
réconcilier les français avec le
parlement parmi les pistes avancées par
françois de rugy permettre aux députés
de voter certains texte en commission et
limiter l'obstruction parlementaire et
on ouvre tout de suite le premier débat
de senna 360 avec maison vitesse sur ce
plateau j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir
jean marie le guen bonjour ancien
secrétaire d'état en charge des
relations avec le parlement dont les
gouvernements valls et 2 merci d'être
avec nous didier moi c'est également sur
ce plateau au bonjour profession
constitutionnel à spécialistes de toutes
les questions parlementaires et de la
procédure parlementaire merci d'être
avec nous et jean louis prévost bonjour
vous êtes journaliste politique l afp en
charge du suivi du sénat première
question pour vous jean marie le guen
qui avait vécu et bien ces procédures
parlementaires de l'intérieur est ce
qu'on a vraiment aujourd'hui besoin de
légiférer plus vite de rendre le travail
parlementaire plus efficace alors je
crois qu'on peut et on doit rendre le
travail plus efficace moins théâtral
plus sérieux
et parfois il faut aller plus vite et en
même temps je ne m'inscris pas
complètement toute action législative ne
doit pas être faite dans l'urgence ce
serait dommageable donc qu'il faudrait
faire la part des choses entre des
textes qui ont besoin de mature et je
pense que tout ce qui tient aux moeurs
aux droits civils et cetera qui sont des
questions de société très importante
méritent souvent une maturation assez
forte
alors que des textes plus économiques et
sociaux de réactivité dans un monde
aujourd'hui très changeante doivent
aller plus vite
voilà enfin il ya beaucoup de redites
dans l'action législative ya beaucoup de
théâtralité au détriment du travail
d'argumentation et de fonds et donc je
pense que effectivement dans les
procédures il doit être possible d'aller
à la fois d'être plus efficace de savoir
aller vite quand il faut aller vite de
prendre le temps qu'il faut lorsque
c'est nécessaire
un savant des propositions qui sont
faites me semble-t-il vont plutôt dans
le bon sens
les hyper et plus vite pour rendre le
travail parlementaire plus efficace ça
existe déjà certaines pistes qui ont été
évoquées notamment et bien une seule
lecture par assemblée on le voit avec le
recours fréquent vous dis honnêtement
mieux travailler au parlement c'est un
thème éternel et si vous reprenez des
textes dits un siècle avant 2004 et 2009
114 la belle époque du parlement on
disait déjà on travaille mal à
l'assemblée à une chambre des députés et
au sénat dont il ya rien de nouveau sous
le soleil
simplement c'est vrai que l'accélération
du temps l'accélération des la société
nécessite peut-être dans certains cas
d'aller un peu plus vite
bon quant à mon problème de savoir s'il
faut faire une seule lecture ou deux
lectures
moi je suis assez attachés au principe
des deux lectures parce que je crois que
si on veut rechercher un accord entre
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat
au moins sur un certain nombre
d'éléments pas pas surtout il faut
prendre un petit peu de temps dans la
navette
et en général c'est pas la deuxième
lecture qui prend le plus de temps
ceci étant il ya la procédure accélérée
elle est mise en oeuvre très fréquemment
elle était très très largement utilisés
sous le précédent quinquennat j'ai pu
les statistiques dans l'année
mais la quasi-totalité de qualité donc
on en était presque là j'ai oubliez pas
que c'est que la deuxième lecture en
fait c'est quand il n'y a pas de
procédure accélérée on a en fait trois
lectures en la réalité celle là oui donc
mais veut dire que même temps deux fois
deux lectures 1h01 2006 juste une
dernière ça fait c'est plus le travail
en commission qui est à chaque fois du
blick du blick et donc ça fait savons
beaucoup quand un ministre présent en
commission par exemple ça c'est non mais
le problème des commissions et est un
vrai problème on espérait après la
réforme de 2008 que le travail en
commission prendrait plus important
c'est que la séance publique de ce fait
reprendre et moins de temps bon il faut
reconnaître dix ans après que c'est un
échec
bon et c'est un échec pas uniquement
pour des raisons institutionnelles mais
en partie pour des raisons de
comportement en réalité des acteurs qui
aime bien dire en séance publique ce
qu'ils ont envie de dire pour une raison
extrêmement simple c'est quel journal
officiel la sténo et que ça permet
d'être alité que vous évoquez on reste
sur cette notion du temps oui sur cette
question de la navette parlementaire est
ce que vous pensez jean louis prévost
qu'on pourrait se suffire d'une seule
lecture est ce qu'il ya quand même des
apports lors des secondes de lecture au
parlement
ou à peu près à chaque fois que fait que
le nez de champ sur l'assemblée soit le
sénat apporte quand même des
améliorations à vos textes qui vient de
l'eau trop chaude ou alors de temps en
temps on était une situation de blocage
et là où on sait bien que c'est
l'assemblée qui a le dernier mot
[Musique]
moi j'ai mon expérience au sénat je ne
sais pas très bien comment ça se passe à
l'assemblée nationale mais ce que
j'observe quand même c'est qu'au sénat
gérard larcher a mis en place une
réforme il y à il ya deux ans qu'il faut
que les choses fonctionnent quand même
mieux le travail en commission peut déjà
élaguer une partie des textes retire à
un certain nombre d'amendements qui ne
sont plus du tout qu'ils ne reviennent
plus comme cela en en séance de même en
ce qui concerne les amendements tout ce
qui n'a pas de caractère normatif et et
retirer des néo l'examen en commission
là on a déjà on assiste déjà une
amélioration et une plus grande rapidité
de l'examen et le travail s'en trouve
véritablement facilité jean-marie le
guen est ce qu'il faut aller jusqu'au
vote de certains textes en commission
sans passer par un débat en séance
publique
oui je pense que ça doit être possible
pour un salon de texte très technique
qui devrait acquis de façon consensuelle
alors ça c'est déjà le cas donc il
faudrait peut-être que le consensus soit
un peu plus stimulée quoi donc peut être
une majorité qualifiée qui permettent et
qui est pas toujours des gens qui pour
des raisons qui n'ont rien à voir avec
le texte en question veulent veulent
bloquer et puis il faut bien le dire
aussi il ya eu quelque chose qui n'a pas
été abordée d'ailleurs dans la dans le
train dans la réflexion me semble-t-il
encore mener c'est tout le problème de
la loi de finances parce que nous sommes
un des rares pays où on passe autant de
temps sur des choses qui ont vraiment
peu à voir avec la conduite du budget de
la nation c'est un mois de l'assemblée
du sénat qui sont utilisés alors que la
partie dite prélèvement est passé en une
semaine mais la partie dite dépenses
alors qu'elle est quasiment inamovible
dans le débat va durer trois semaines là
je pense que si on avait été fidèle à
une réforme qui a été mise en place
c'est à dire là ce qu'on a appelé en son
temps la lolf organique sur le film et
les finances publiques
et si on avait vraiment travailler
autour de cette idée là notamment dans
les commissions on n'aurait pas un mois
entier de travail où on ne va pas au
fond des choses car on n'est pas au fond
si on n'est pas sur l'efficacité on est
encore sur l'affichage de la dépense
publique et pas sur l'efficacité de la
dépense publique c'est à dire que au
lieu de de partir de ce qui ne va pas ou
de ce qui peut être amélioré on part
comme si on avait une page blanche
chaque à chaque budget est là
on perd beaucoup de temps et
d'efficacité du compte du point de vue
du contrôle parlementaire
on sait aussi que françois de rugy veut
revoir peut-être bien le droit
d'amendement c'est l'existence même ça
d'un parlementaire est ce qu'il faut le
limité on voyait le président de
l'assemblée dire que finalement quentin
le même amendement est présenté
plusieurs fois au sein d'un même groupe
ça là où plus vraiment de sens c'est
vrai qu'il ya quelque chose d'un peu
aberrant dans la pratique de
l'amendement
mais en même temps c'est un droit
fondamental d'un député ou d'un sénateur
je crois que il faut pas non plus
considérer que le parlement est une
entreprise dont la productivité se
mesure à la rapidité d'adoption des lois
je crois qu'il faut trouver un critère
de hack du bon travail parlementaire qui
est différent c'est à dire une bonne loi
et c'est vrai qu'il ya des lois de fonds
il ya des lois de circonstance bon on a
vu un certain nombre de ministres d'hier
à la tribune je vous présente un projet
de loi qui est ce anticipe le prochain
projet de loi vous souvient par exemple
madame trautmann à jour est émise la
culture de la communication disant ce
n'est qu'une étape dans les histoires
des lois sa communication
alors les amendements ça existe est-ce
qu'on peut les limites et plus il ya
déjà un certain nombre de règles et
pratiques
bon on voit aussi que des amendements
qui sont contraires à la constitution le
conseil constitutionnel passe son temps
à propos d'à peu près toutes les lois a
déclaré contraire à la caution ce qu'on
appelle les cavaliers législatifs
c'est-à-dire des amendements qui ont été
déposés à tort bon ça prend aussi des
oiseaux les temps sont bons il faut pas
non il faut quand même se mettre dans la
tête je crois que c'est important quand
et surtout quand on voit par exemple les
images de l'assemblée nationale et du
sénat que le parlement est un lieu où
l'on doit discuter un lieu où on doit
confronter un certain nombre d'avis et
il ne faut pas escamoté en réalité ce
qui fait le coeur de la démocratie
parlementaire c'est-à-dire le dialogue
entre le gouvernement et sa majorité qui
logiquement font un et les oppositions
jeudi l'est parce qu'en ce moment il y
en a plusieurs mais peu importe et le
cas échéant
l'opposition entre la majorité de
l'assemblée nationale et la majorité du
sénat
alors il qu'en tant que c'est urgent on
y arrive regarder la loi d'habilitation
sur le code du travail
bon ça a été adopté en moins d'un mois
gros ce brusque état des lieux
parfaitement raisonnable compte tenu du
calendrier bon et il faut aussi se
mettre dans la tête parce que le giro il
y avait très peu de revêtement sur deux
innovations ce que j ai pas d'amendement
et parce qu'il n'est pas d'autre projet
qui traînait derrière
bon c'est le gouvernement qui en réalité
fournit les textes pour l'essentiel au
parlement évent m'bala il faut peut-être
aussi essayé j'en ai un peu moins
j'entends ce discours depuis très
longtemps
mais cette inflation législative chacun
est fautif jean louis prévost là on voit
que les propositions dont nous débattons
sur ce plateau et même de l'assemblée
nationale comment elles peuvent être
reçues perçue ici au sénat alors au
sénat donc là une réforme a déjà eu lieu
il ya deux engagés par gérard larcher et
dont les effets se font sentir
véritablement que dit au quotidien
il ya eu d'abord l'organisation de
l'agenda des sénateurs le ce président
larcher a décidé de bloquer trois jours
en séance le mardi le mercredi le jeudi
on débordant de temps en temps sur le
lundi ou le
vendredi cela pour permettre une
meilleure présence de l'ensemble des
sénateurs aussi bien meilleure présence
en séance mais également dans les
travaux de commission et pour leur
permettre d'être dans ces constructions
dans leur département le lundi enfin du
vendredi au lundi il passait le week-end
donc il ya eu ça permet également de
lutter contre l'absentéisme qui est
fortement décriée a que des deux salles
différentes mesures notamment un
renforcement du rôle des commissions
également quelque chose de très
important
mais qui d'après peut-être pas comme
véritablement en allégement du travail
législatif
mais les votes des grands textes
généralement v'nu à l'issue du débat
c'est à dire que si un texte l'examen
d'un projet de loi se terminer dans la
nuit du vendredi au samedi à 3 heures du
matin le vote solennel avait lieu dans
la foulée jusqu'à 5 heures du matin un
samedi inutile de vous dire qu'il n'y
avait pas beaucoup de sénateurs qui
n'était pas dans un état très très frais
allez donc le le bureau du sénat le
bureau du sénat a décidé de déplacer ces
votes solennels de lait concentré au
mardi après-midi ce qui permet la
présence de l'ensemble des sénateurs ce
qui permet aussi d'avoir un débat plus
apaisé en ce qui concerne les
explications de vote avec des sénateurs
un peu plus frais qui savent vraiment ce
qu'ils font c'est ici si j'ose
m'exprimer ainsi
jean-marie le guen à penser qu'il ya un
consensus entre françois de rugy et
gérard larcher sur ces questions de
réforme de la procédure parlementaire on
sait ici que le sénat ait me prendre le
temps c'est une chambre justement qui se
définit par les discussions plutôt dans
la longueur dans l'hémicycle il n'ya pas
de temps programmé ici au sénat
contrairement à ce qui se fait à
l'assemblée
oui même si je suis d'accord sur le fait
que 20 mois ont donc secret d'état aux
relations avec le parlement j'ai jamais
eu de difficultés avec la majorité
sénatoriale avec le sénat qui a bien
travaillé mais j'allais dire d'un
certain point de vue il me semble que
c'est moins le problème entre
l'assemblée et le sénat que
à l'intérieur même de l'assemblée
nationale où très souvent les choses
sont beaucoup moins régulée et évitons
quand même de donner l'impression d'une
politique où finalement le spectaculaire
l'emportent sur le rationnel sur
l'argumentaire etc donc je crois
vraiment qu'il faut se rapprocher des
démocraties modernes qui travaille au
fond les textes et d'ailleurs évidemment
évitons aussi de de légiférer à outrance
je pense que devrait avoir une saisine
il y en a un peu d'ailleurs au sénat
même façon vous savez on n'a pas le
droit de présenter un amendement quand
on fait des dépenses en qu'elle soit
gagée simple bon ben je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup d'amendements qui pourrait
sauter si ce n'était pas des textes qui
propose une régulation de niveau
réglementaire et nantes pas législatifs
c'est-à-dire que si on n'essaie pas de
tout faire remonter dans la loi mais
l'essai au décret ce qui est au décret
laisser à la circulaire ce qui est à la
circulaire façon avoir plus de souplesse
eh bien on y gagnerait beaucoup mais
tous les lobbys professionnels et autres
évidemment souhaite que
l'organisation de leur profession
appartiennent à la loi c'est à dire que
pratiquement l'organisation la
profession peut pas être changé pendant
cinq ou six ans parce que le temps de
mettre à l'ordre du jour détaillé et
terra que ce soit votée que ça passait
quoi ça prend une intense où ça c'est ce
type d'attitude qui est fréquente dans
la manière de légiférer et bien abouti à
des blocages fameux blocage ceux cités
françaises où on peut pas véritablement
bougé comme il convient la
réglementation des différentes
professions des différents champs
d'activités économiques et sociaux donc
il ya vraiment un effort à faire me
semble-t-il pour alléger la loi pour la
rendre plus réactive et j'espère que le
sénat et l'assemblée se mettront
d'accord je pense pas que les
propositions de de rugy soit des
propositions qui soient à la question du
sénat c'est à la fois on entend vos
arguments il faut quand même prendre le
temps de bien examiner une loi de
l'améliorer de la modifier et pourtant
il ya dans l'opinion publique aussi une
volonté accrue de réformes d'aller vite
alors est ce que on peut bien faire
correspondre les désirs de l'opinion
publique et le travail oui mais je crois
que ça c'était un effort de pédagogie à
faire de la part du gouvernement et des
parlementaires
le temps de la loi ce n'est pas le temps
du journal télévisé du 20h
bon faut quand même qu'on voit qu'on se
dise bon il y a des lois dont l'impact
est rapide et on ne légifère pas pour
l'instant on va dire on évoquait tout à
leurs victimes en les grandes lois bon
civile ou sur les choses la société même
les lois pénales et loi bioéthique etc
on légifère pour un mois un an deux ans
et donc il faut prendre un petit peu
dans certains cas mais dans notre cas on
légifère quand on fait du droit du
travail ou du droit fiscal
là on sait qu'on légifère pour du court
terme parce qu automatiquement deux ans
après on va vous dire il faut faire
autre chose donc peut-être faut-il
distinguer dans ces cas mais pour
revenir aux questions vous posiez je
crois que quand gérard larcher arrivera
est d'accord avec françois de rugy
à condition que les droits du sénat ne
soit pas mis en cause non et il est du
rôle du président du sénat en réalité de
défendre la singularité du sénat
c'est-à-dire sa participation à la
confection de la loi et viserait droit
de revenir d'un mot sur le problème des
loin
commission bien longtemps qu on dit
qu'il faut que les lois soient adoptées
en commission
ça se fait en italie etc
réglementairement d'ailleurs on pourrait
parfaitement géré travailler en
commissions simplement donné le rapport
en séance publique
et on passe très rapidement on le fait
pour les voix de ratification de traités
et on en fait ça va très vite
bon simplement il faut que le débat en
commission dans ce cas là soient
publiques bon parce que le souvent bon
parce que l'élaboration de la loi elle
doit se faire sous le regard alors qu'en
théorie des citoyens en réalité beaucoup
des groupes d'intérêts nous nous sommes
d'accord là dessus mais la publicité du
débat de confection de la loi est
essentielle dans une démocratie un mot
en mai prévu justement sur ces
consciences est ce qu'on peut attendre
entre françois que juré de régis pardon
alors de pour continuer ce que sur ce
que disait monsieur maus la publicité
des débats au sein des commissions
d'examen quand même au sénat où la
plupart du temps elles sont elles sont
effectivement public et vous pouvez
retrouver leurs comptes rendus qui est
publié sur le site intégralement sur le
site du sénat
maintenant s'il concerne monsieur de
rugy et musées cher à l'archet gels et
j'ai l'impression qu'ils n'ont pas
encore tellement pris long l'un et
l'autre donc monsieur de rouge il a été
élu en juin il y à une période à la
séance extraordinaire en juillet et eu
beaucoup de travail et à ce moment là
monsieur larcher maintenant et
à peu près partout en france où il avait
eu le soutien les candidats de son camp
pour l'élection sénatoriale
je pense qu'ils parleront de tout seul
lorsque monsieur larcher s'il est réélu
il a priori je pense qu'il n'y a pas
grande
il paraît pas beaucoup de mauvais il n'y
a pas beaucoup de mauvaises surprises à
attendre
je crois qu'il va falloir attendre
octobre pour qui le ce contact et b et
qu'ils se mettent d'accord sur un sur un
calendrier
alors il ya quand même la question des
réformes institutionnelles aussi qui
fait partie des démissions dont les a
chargé le président de la république
ils ont tous les deux pour une mission
de faire des propositions en ce qui
concerne les réformes institutionnelles
alors la question est ce qu'ils seront
sur la même ligne ou non ça c'est
l'avenir qui nous a parlé maintenant de
l'annnonce de la vente du siège du parti
socialiste solférino s'associent de
remous quelle est votre position
on écoute et je pense que d'une façon
générale il faut que le parti s'est
hissée ch tourner la page
là il ya par ailleurs une nécessité de
vendre ce siège qui eut à mettre venue
d'un certain point de vue le symbole
d'un parti enfermé donc voilà il faut
tourner c'était c'est pas le sait pas le
siège historique il a été le siège
historique d'une période 1980 jusqu'à
aujourd'hui c'est d'ailleurs ça
correspond un cycle
voilà j'ai pas de va faire de la
nostalgie mobilières merci cette
hypothèse était donc sur la table depuis
plusieurs mois loin de satisfaire tout
le monde les explications de stéphane à
mal et les cadres du ps foule peut-être
cet escalier pour la dernière fois
l'objectif de la vente et de renflouer
les caisses relancer le parti après la
défaite aux législatives ce qui compte
c'est la question de la position de
l'action d'un parti politique
aujourd'hui à l'ère du numérique a l'air
de comment on continue à porter
l'émancipation individuelle pour que
l'équipe c'est tout ça que nous allons
porter et donc le siège n'est qu'un
outil n'est pas une finalité en soi un
outil trop onéreux mais qui reste le
symbole d'une génération
certains cadres semblent gênés par la
méthode bay qui prend la décision lance
un bureau national sur la présentation
semble-t-il des comptes par le trésorier
du parti socialiste jusqu'ici d'ailleurs
toujours pas eu de 2-2-2 de présenter la
libération répond un processus opaque
selon stéphane le foll pour françois
rebsamen toutes les instances du parti
doivent être impliqués je vais pas
parler forcément de vote des militants
et j'ai parlé d'abord d'information
éventuellement d'un conseil national
on va voir comment les choses se passent
mais elle se passe dans la transparence
c'est pour moi une condition essentielle
du côté des militants les avis sont
partagés mais tous sont d'accord sur un
point ils auraient dû être consultés
moi je pensais que ça allait être
l'aboutissement d'une concertation est
effectivement pourquoi pas d'un même
c'est est ce que je préférais d'un vote
des militants
les militants sont complètement mis de
côté et c'est une une minorité qui n'a
plus de légitimité d'ailleurs qui prend
des décisions
certains militants voient dans cette
vente l'opportunité d'installer le siège
dans un quartier plus populaire pour
recoller avec la philosophie de la
gauche et pour évoquer à la vente du
siège de solférino alain bergounioux
historien du parti socialiste est notre
invité il répond aux questions de sa
verrière break
le face à face et tout de suite
[Musique]
bonjour alain bergounioux bonjour le ps
a donc acté hier soir le principe de la
vente de son siège historique de la rue
de solférino est-ce que c'est aussi le
symbole de la fin du ps
non parce que le parti socialiste ne
puis on peut dire sa naissance depuis
1905 a changé cette fois de sièges dans
paris et françois mitterrand trois fois
donc c'est disons que c'est la fin d'un
cycle
après les défaites électorales du
printemps mais c'est une autre histoire
qui commence et donc personne ne connaît
l'issue
alors les dirigeants du parti hier soir
parlé d'une décision inéluctable compte
tenu vous l'avez dit de l'état des
finances est ce qu'il ya vraiment
urgence à vendre on a l'impression quand
même qu'il faut liquider le passé très
vite
non je sais pas je pense que ce pas la
liquider le passé c'est j'ose dire c'est
liquider le passif dernière le passif du
déficit déficit financier puisque vous
savez que les partis politiques
aujourd'hui sont largement financés par
l'état selon les résultats aux élections
législatives au nombre de voix est là
quand on passe entre 2012 et demi le
prochain budget 2010 8,2 de 20 millions
d'euros à 7 millions d'euros
donc vous faites le calcul sur cinq ans
aux millions de déficit
donc à partir de ce moment là il fait le
choix est simple soit on privilégie
l'action politique
or un parti c'est quand même pour agir
pour parler pour diffuser préparer les
élections soit le maintien dans des
lieux donc la priorité a été donnée à
l'action ont néanmoins néanmoins vous
auriez pu choisir de faire une
hypothèque sur justement la rue mais ça
non ça a été fait en 95 ou non 93 mais
ce n'était pas suffisant
parce que je sais donner les chiffres
100 millions de déficit
ce n'était pas suffisant et donc le
choix qui a été fait quand même très
très largement c'est le choix de
l'action
et puis il faut pas oublier que le parti
ce n'est pas qu'un siège parisien
c'est des fédérations sont des lieux
dans les départements et ce qui est
vraiment prioritaire c'est pouvoir aider
les l'implantation locale départementale
et qui est souvent à reconstruire donc
le bas tous ne se symbolise pas sur un
seul siège parisien
est-ce qu'il faut vérifier les comptes
pour être certain que ces décisions est
inéluctable on entendu certains
dirigeants du parti ce matin demander
cela une vérification des comptes
mais les comptes
je pense tout le monde il ya une
commission des comptes donc c'est assez
transparente tout le monde les connaîtra
mais le point essentiel c'est qu'il ya
un déficit majeur pour les cinq ans à
venir
et puis avait déjà eu pour la campagne
présidentielle et puis pour le
financement du parti des emprunts donc
on ne peut pas laisser monter la dette
et reculer les décisions de mois en mois
et d'années en années parce que le
passif serait encore plus important et
franchement c'est l'action politique
décentralisée qui est qui est majeur qui
a pris cette décision est ce que c'est
jean christophe cambadélis je rappelle
que vous étiez présent hier soir au
bureau national au moment où la décision
a été annoncée oui jean christophe
cambadélis a il ya eu un débat au bureau
national sur le rapport du trésorier
évidemment mais c'est lui qui est encore
jusqu'au 30 septembre premiers
secrétaires et il a pris la
responsabilité sur ses épaules de
proposer cette cette décision et je
crois qu'il a manifesté là un courage
certain
est-ce qu'il faut que cette vente
l'addition de cette vente soit entérinée
par le conseil national ou même un vote
militant ou parle d'un vote lors du
conseil national du 30 septembre mais
formellement ce n'est pas nécessaire
parce qu'à la limite s'il fallait un
vote
ça serait le vote des militants donc il
faudra du temps dément formellement ce
n'est pas nécessaire symboliquement mais
ça ne s'est jamais produit lorsque
françois mitterrand a décidé de quitter
la cité malesherbes pour aller 7 bis
place du palais bourbon il admet il a
demandé à personne
il n'y a pas eu de vote et quand léon
blum est réparti entre les deux guerres
de la rue vite en masse n ya pas eu de
vote non plus c'est la responsabilité
d'une direction d'utiliser les mots les
moyens du paradis alors justement
pourquoi françois mitterrand a choisi de
s'installer rue de solférino en 1981 il
avait d'abord choisi
la place du palais bourbon et ça veut
tout dire pour françois mitterrand et là
on était dans les années 70 qui était un
grand parlementaire ce qui comptait
c'était la proximité de l'assemblée
nationale et il était là 150 mètres de
l'hémicycle c'est assemblée nationale et
pour lui c'était c'était le lieu du
pouvoir pour un parti qui était avant
1980 un parti d'opposition donc là il
disait françois mitterrand disait il
faut être proche des lieux de pouvoir
qu'elles nous avons vocation à être un
parti de gouvernement bien sûr il y
avait aussi cette volonté de montrer que
le parti socialiste était là et puis en
plus c'était évidemment extrêmement
commode pour les élus les et put et qui
sont quand même majoritaire dans la
direction pour pouvoir en cinq minutes
être à l'assemblée voté revenir donc
c'est une commodité politique
mais alors pourquoi juston que 40 ans
plus tard c'est une adresse trop
bourgeoise la russie où il a joué dans
l'arctique ghouila je crois que c'est
satan au cou et je crois que la ccsg
j'ose dire ccc assez maniable une
mauvaise manière de poser la question
parce que ce qui intéresse les français
c'est pas le lieu
c'est l'action c'est le bilan c'est les
propositions c'est l'incarnation
mais un lieu n'a jamais fait un parti
même si au bout d'un certain nombre de
décennies à une identification un peu
sentimental et médiatique c'est le cas
justement bien sûr mais et la rue de
solferino sûr mais aimé autrefois
c'était la cité malesherbes et le parti
socialiste a quitté la cité malesherbes
il y avait une nostalgie des anciens
mais ça ne l'a pas empêché de gagner les
élections en 1981 où lon les lieux ne
sont pas sont importants mais ne sont
quand même pas l'essentiel
elle a beaucoup jugent justement que ça
va permettre aux parties de quitter le
7e arrondissement de paris pour une
adresse et un siège qui serait on va le
dire un peu moins tapageur plus proche
des valeurs de gauche oui mais encore
une fois la scène je crois que c'est une
mauvaise mauvaise analyse c'est pas le
siège qui est ta page joueurs ont dans
ce siège on a gagné on a perdu
et les et les françaises qui est ce qui
est important pour eux c'est c'est
l'action le bilan l'image l'incarnation
déjà ségolène royal à l'époque oui mais
alors on peut considérer que ça comme un
instrument de communication mais
franchement c'est pas l'essentiel et si
on fait une mauvaise politique dans un
lieu et dans un quartier populaire
ça ne changera absolument rien au
résultat et je voudrais pas être trop
cruel mais par d'autres exemples le
siège de parti dans les quartiers
populaires et qui n'ont pas enrayé leur
difficulté mais symboliquement ou sera
le prochain siège avec lui en avait
parlé hier soir oui mais passera devant
paris marie hier soir oui ça sera dans
paris mais pour l'instant les dents
paraît pas en proche banlieue
mais ça dépend ce qu'on appelle la
proche banlieue enfin tout ce qui est
joignable par métro dans un
arrondissement populaire
ben on verra bien pour l'instant et est
la décision le choix n'a pas été fait et
il faut quand même prospecter il faut
d'abord vendre avant d'acheter
c'est l'économie familiale mais c'est
quand même important
et puis il faut prospecter pour
l'instant là il n'y a pas de décision
prise
stéphane le foll s'est dit ce matin très
triste est ce que vous vous trouvez que
la décision n'est pas à l'autre à la
hauteur de l'ambition l'ambition la
reconstruction du parti puisque c'est
précisément là où on est le ps
aujourd'hui il ya deux éléments la
tristesse tout le monde la partage pas
ce que c'est c'est lé symbole d'un échec
politique d'un échec électoral et en
même temps la reconstruction c'est
d'abord l'action s'est pas c'est pas les
pierres aussi belle et aussi attachante
soit elles ne font pas l'action ce qui
compte pour un parti c'est de pouvoir
agir c'est de pouvoir parler c'est de
pouvoir diffuser de soutenir ces
fédérations ces sections donc ses fins
le folk et un militant aguerri sait très
bien que ce qui compte c'est l'action
quarante ans rue de solférino si vous
deviez vous ne retenir qu'une seule
chose à faire et non ce serait excellent
souvenir
ja il ya le sou il ya deux souvenirs qui
sont lire un même personnage ans
françois mitterrand il ya le souvenir de
la victoire de 80 la nuit de 80 et puis
a le souvenir du vivier non c'était un
peu jeune et en mai la seconde ce le
souvenir du départ de françois
mitterrand en 1995 lorsqu'il a quitté
l'elysée il est venu à solférino faire
alors c'était un homme malade comme il
l'avait dit c'était la fin de sa vie
politique et aussi la fin de sa vie et
c'était 1 c'était un moment très
émouvant très bien merci beaucoup merci
alain goudey d'avoir répondu à nos
questions merci merci voilà pour cet
entretien enregistré un peu plus tôt cet
après-midi calmer la grogne des élus et
renouer le dialogue avant les
sénatoriales voilà à quoi cet atelier
edouard philippe devant la conférence
des villes organisé par l'association
france urbaine
le premier ministre sans tabou a abordé
tous les sujets qui fâchent des contrats
aidés à la taxe d'habitation sans
oublier la baisse des dotations quentin
calmer opération déminage pour le
premier ministre ce matin en ouverture
de la conférence des villes qui réunit
les 2000 agglomération métropole et
grandes villes de france
edouard philippe est immédiatement
revenu sur le dossier chaud du moment
la baisse des dotations de l'état il ne
s'agit pas de 13 milliards d'euros de
baisses de la dépense locale
nous vous demandons de maîtriser votre
dépenses y compris votre dépense
tendanciel qui est en cause c'est très
différent
vos dépenses vont continuer à progresser
mais vous devez infléchir la courbe pour
les maires présents ce matin à la
conférence des villes on note
l'évolution dans la méthode de
l'exécutif après plusieurs annonces très
mal perçues par les élus locaux sur les
dotations les emplois aidés ou encore la
taxe d'habitation
aujourd'hui ces édiles veulent croire à
une nouvelle dynamique
on ne voulait pas que ce soit un coup de
rabot brutale tout de suite il a adopté
semble t il une méthode que l'ont
appelée de nos voeux qui tient compte de
la croissance de la diversité de nos
territoires et qui donc va nous
permettre de respirer pour d'autres élus
notamment à gauche rien à faire le début
de quinquennat est raté pour ce qui est
des relations avec les collectivités
territoriales
nous sommes porteurs dans cette drogue
parce qu elle nous vient du terrain le
premier ministre a dit que les mères
c'était vraiment l'incarnation de la
proximité et du terrain et bah oui et ce
qui remonte du terrain
c'est un profond mécontentement le
sentiment qu'après la conférence
nationale du territoire il y a eu trop
pris puisque toute une série de tuiles
l'heure sans tomber sur la tête pendant
l'été des élus qui vont être très
attentif lors de la présentation du
projet de loi de finances mi octobre
déjà les associations des maires de
france des départements et des régions
ont annoncé vouloir maintenir la
pression lors de leur congrès réunies
dans les prochaines semaines
alors à l'occasion de la conférence
ville vit la france urbaine on va tout
de suite s'intéresser aux rapports entre
l'état les collectivités aux équilibres
territoriaux tels qu'ils sont conçus par
le chef de l'état alors que 80% de la
population française habitant aux 20% du
territoire et que la tradition jacobine
centralisatrice perdure comment penser
cette nouvelle carte des territoires
on va en parler avec mes invités sur ce
plateau frédéric gilli bonjour vous êtes
jeune chercheur à l'école urbaine de
sciences po merci d'être avec nous
michel cantal dupart bonjour vous êtes
architecte urbaniste vous avez remis en
2013 à françois hollande un rapport sur
le grand paris merci d'être avec nous
vincent aussi où ce bonjour vous êtes un
chef du département économie finance de
francs stratégie et j'accueille et enfin
jean baptiste forêt bonjour vous êtes
rédacteur en chef délégué de la gazette
des communes première question pour vous
frédéric gilli on entendu ce matin
edouard fini beaucoup parlé de la carte
des territoires de cette carte des
territoires
on sait que son quinquennat de françois
hollande il a lu l'adoption de la loi
nôtre est ce que vous diriez que la
carte des territoires aujourd'hui est en
train réellement de se modifier en
france alors c'est toujours compliqué de
rentrer dans ces questions par des
logiques de cartes de compétence et de
délimitation je pense que en amont de ça
il faut se poser la question de pourquoi
est-ce qu'on discute de tout ça est ce
qu'il ya un sujet ou par des coupes et
comment fonctionne aujourd'hui notre
économie et nos relations sociales dans
les territoires indubitablement le
fonctionnement de nos territoires a
changé et ce qu'on appelle les
métropoles prennent place de plus en
plus importante dans la circulation des
richesses dans la circulation de
l'information directe donc il ya une
légitimité à se poser cette question là
ça pose deux problèmes le premier c'est
considérer que les métropoles un rôle
central dans le fonctionnement des
territoires ne veut pas dire que les
métropoles sont l'alpha et l'oméga de
toutes les politiques territoriales
elles ont besoin de leurs périphéries et
aujourd'hui elles tendent à trop les
ignorer et le deuxième sujet c'est
considéré qu' il ya besoin de redécouper
pour réfléchir aux compétences et aux
limitations ne doit pas se faire sans
passer par une case je dirais
de démocratie locale mais qu'ils soient
pas simplement les élus qu'ils soient
aussi les habitants pour rediscuter
collectivement d'oeuf la façon dont on
vit dans les territoires et la façon
dont on vit dans le pays et ça je dirais
que depuis 5 6 ans ces questions de
territoire elles ont tendance à les
prédications d'élus et pas des autres
invités
on va tout de suite retrouvé michael
aimait son directeur de l'hôtel de ville
à paris c'était christian estrosi lui il
aimerait bien voir la métropole niçoise
justement fusionné avec le département
des aldudes pourtant si on a entendu
dans le discours à l'instant du ministre
de l'intérieur une volonté qui allait
finalement de ce gouvernement avec les
élus locaux c'est quelque chose que
aujourd'hui vous soulignez de la part du
gouvernement oui parce que nous n'étions
plus habitués depuis un certain nombre
d'années
avoir un gouvernement qui se montre être
un véritable interlocuteur des élus
locaux
c'est vrai pas le cas cet été et il ya
eu des annonces mois de juin début
juillet qui pouvait nous inquiéter avec
un risque de réduction brutale de près
de 13 milliards d'euros de l'effort de
l'état en direction des collectivités en
vue de réduire les déficits publics de
manière globale entre le déficit public
de l'état et ceux des collectivités mais
sans rentrer dans le fond de l'effort
qui est fait par un certain nombre de
noms d'entre nous aujourd'hui les
collectivités locales c'est 70% de la
commande publique dans notre pays on
cherche la croissance on veut créer des
emplois on veut lutter contre le chômage
ce sont les collectivités qui
investissent le plus et contribuer et
certaines d'entre elles d'ailleurs on
fait beaucoup d'économies comme celle
leurs destinées de laquelle je préside
nice sa métropole d'économies de
fonctionnement ces dernières années pour
privilégier notre marge
d'autofinancement et pouvoir investir
sur les équipements publics qui sont
attendus pour améliorer la qualité de
vie les transports les déplacements
l'université attirer des investissements
qui touche aux start up à la recherche
et au développement pour cela que vous
lancez sera matin la question c'est pour
cela que vous lancez un grand mouvement
avec les élus locaux
en parlerons dans quelques temps et en
tous cas il y ait une réalité c'est que
l'exécutif et le législatif ne peuvent
pas continuer à faire des réformes sont
proposés un véritable pacte de confiance
comme vient de le faire d'ailleurs
gérard collomb à l'ensemble des grands
décideurs de ce pays c'est à dire les
décideurs des territoires merci beaucoup
créé sur les 110 d'avoir répondu en
direct à nos questions gérard collomb va
arriver d'ici quelques secondes pour
répondre lui aussi en direct aux
questions du public saidal dans un
instant michel cantal dupart je voudrais
vous interrogé sur cet essor des
métropoles qui semble à présent
inéluctable comment peut-il se faire
sans qu'il n'y ait un effet et bien
peut-être secondaires néfastes notamment
sur les départements sur le reste du
territoire
est-ce que je ne risque pas d'accentuer
la fracture territoriale alors on est
prisonniers de notre histoire et on
efface des défis énormes on est
prisonnier notre histoire n'oublions pas
que ce pays a été découpée en
département va prendre l'exemple du
département pour rendre commode
les relations des territoires à l'état
et l'état a mis partout un représentant
qui était un commissaire de la
république ou un préfet qui était
atteignable par tout individu tout
citoyen dans la journée voilà si on
considère ce si important les relations
de l'état et des citoyens
aujourd'hui peut se faire de
pratiquement tous les territoires à
quelques exceptions près dans la journée
donc on dit ça pour montrer montré un
certain nombre de choses d'autre part il
ya la formation et on est votre le
l'organe où nous sommes diffuse dans la
totalités même au delà des frontières de
notre pays donc on a
il ya une information qui est
complètement différent non qu'on a une
organisation très des êtres que tout le
monde trouve que mode par rapport à des
affectations de compétences qui sont du
ressort de la région du département de
la commune enfin tout ça dans des
réunions de synthèse mais beaucoup de
gens autour d'une table de ça coûte très
cher épouvantablement faire et selon les
tendances politiques on est pour
projet ou contre tel projet j'ai entendu
monsieur estrosi qui désirent fusionner
les alpes-maritimes et sa commune
c'est ce que c'est ce qu'a fait
l'agglomération de lyon
même si très bien ses formes c'est même
formidable en valeur on disait les
métropoles se font fidler de leurs
périphéries bhl c'est une façon une
autre façon d'intégrer la périphérie à
la à la métropole régionale bon ça c'est
la première chose la deuxième chose
c'est tout ce qui est en train de se
passer au niveau économique et qui tue
un certain nombre de petites villes
c'est à dire qu'on a une mentalité de
clocher on est attaché au clocher des
tas de gens se sentent en totale des
espérances parce qu'ils voient tous
fermés ils voient tous partir les
emplois les commerces le boucher le
boulanger
y'a plus rien et ça fait d'une certaine
désespérance comment peut-on inverser
cette tendance
alors nous les gens en aient raison
lycée l'automobile qui a cassé tout ça
ce sont les grandes surfaces à il ya des
choses comme ça que tout le monde pense
en fait les choses évoluent les communes
est lé fruit des paroisses aujourd'hui
un curé je prends ça comme exemple un
curé gère une certain nombre d'églises
partout donc c'est tout ça aussi évolué
c'est moi je vois je travaille à l'heure
actuelle beaucoup sur les parce que ça
ça dépend des communes les marchés les
marchés qui joue les gens sont très
attentifs aux circuits courts un certain
nombre de choses combien de mères
travaillent aujourd'hui sur la
rénovation de leur marché sur l'année
d'innovation du bâtiment marché sur son
emplacement et sur les gens qui viennent
à l'intérieur et ça c'est une réelle
alternative une réelle économie est un
réel dynamisme avec tout ce qui peut se
passer autour et ça c'est des choses
simples ça valorise l'agriculteur d'à
côté est
ça fait plaisir à tout le monde c'est
dans cet équilibre territorial difficile
à atteindre on le voit qu'elles sont et
bien là quelle est la vision d' emmanuel
macron on sait qu'il est il la favorite
est justement l'essor de ces métropoles
et s'était rappelée avec les fusions de
départements sur le modèle de ce qui a
pu se faire entre jarre colons et michel
mercier à lyon avec le département du
rhône ça c'est un modèle vers lequel il
faut tendre selon vous alors bon là je
vais pas exprimer la vision du président
de la république france tratégie auquel
j'appartiens est un un institut de
réflexion de proposition qui est non
partisan qui se base sur des analyses
objectives et donc dé travail pourtour
de l'identification des problèmes et cet
enjeu effectivement de la dynamique des
métropoles est un des enjeux bien
évidemment que nous avons identifiés
comme central pour la décennie à venir
la relation entre les métropoles et
leurs territoires comme comme l'on dit
monsieur campagne par est est un des
enjeux centraux de nos sociétés du vivre
ensemble et on voit quand on observe de
près ces dynamiques qui a des métropoles
en fait qui entraîne les territoires
voisins
c'est le cas billon par exemple c'est le
cas de marseille également aussi et
auquel on pense moins l'agglomération
d'aix-marseille la métropole d'aix
marseille
en revanche c'est moins le cas de
bordeaux c'est moins le cas de lille
c'est moins le cas de toulouse par
exemple est donc là les enjeux c'est de
comprendre pourquoi dans certains cas
les territoires les métropoles
entraînent avec elles leur territoire
dans une relation vertueuse et c'est en
ce sens que à la fois d'un point de vue
économique et social mais aussi bien
entendu des structures de la démocratie
parce que la france est un état
centralisé depuis les lois de
décentralisation des années 80 on a
passé des compétences aux collectivités
territoriales on n'a pas repensé et les
lieux de la démocratie en fonction des
compétences qui ont été transmises dans
ce qui a donné la perception du
millefeuille territorial mais qui pose
énormément de problèmes parce que nos
citoyens nos concitoyens pensent que le
maire par exemple est celui qui détient
le plus de pouvoir dans leur vie de tous
les jours or on sait bien qu'aujourd'hui
beaucoup des sujets les plus importants
comme les transports comme le
développement économique l'emploi etc
sont dans les communautés
d'agglomération dont la représentation
démocratique n'est pas à ce niveau là
idem pour les régions qui ont une
représentation démocratique
les conseils départementaux c'est pas
qu'un problème de représentation
démocratique
si vous parlez fait d'entraînement et
aussi les conséquences économiques de
l'essor de ces métropoles sur les zones
périphériques ça qu'est ce qu'on a prévu
absolument la loi matam et la loi notre
n'avait avait prévu que c'était les
régions qui s'occupait de l' équilibre
des territoires alors que les métropoles
devait plutôt se concentrer sur leur
propre développement économique
le pacte ensuite entre le pacte est un
métropole de 2 juillet 2016 a prévu
justement que les métropoles devait
aussi se préoccuper de leurs impacts de
leur influence sur les territoires
avoisinants
donc là dessus c'est serait interrogé
sur les politiques de transport urbain
justement qui peuvent avoir un double
avantage à la fois favoriser la
croissance le dynamisme économique de
ces métropoles mais en même temps
diffusé enfin disons égaliser les
opportunités d'accès aux services
publics aux opportunités d'emploi des
personnes qui sont hors des attendus
dans ce débat en voulant favoriser
finalement l'émergence des métropoles
est ce qu'on n'a pas pris le risque
d'accentuer d'aggraver ce qu'on appelle
cette fracture territoriale et qu'on a
pu qui a pu expliquer notamment une
partie du vote frontiste lors de la
dernière présidentielle
oui tout à fait en tout cas dans la
perception des habitants on est
aujourd'hui un peu dans paris et le
désert français sur le plan économique
c'est beaucoup plus contestable mais il
ya un certain nombre de populations qui
se sentent très clairement abandonné la
difficulté pour une mamelle macron c'est
qu'il a ici qui doit on veut avant tout
sa victoire
on sent trop grands centres urbains donc
son projet territorial s'appuie quand
même avant tout sur sur les métropoles
en particulier sur la métropole du grand
paris emmanuel macron considère qu'il
faut des locomotives pour irriguer
ensuite le reste du territoire et son
grand projet sur le plan métropolitain à
mon sens c'est la métropole du grand
paris aujourd'hui cette structure est un
nain politique financier la métropole a
un budget de 70 millions d'euros enfin
c'est ridicule pour la première région
d'or pour la première région d'europe
donc il est vraiment attendu au tournant
il doit on doit intervenir là dessus le
23 le 23 octobre ne mette de l'ordre
charles de gaulle avait dit à de
l'ouvrier qui était le grand ordonnateur
de la rénovation de la région capitale
dans les années 60 mais témoin de
l'ordre dans ce bordel c'est un peu la
mission aujourd'hui du président
jupitérien parce que parce qu'on a mille
feuilles absolument invraisemblable de
on a les communes on allait les
établissements publics territoriaux les
départements des différents échelons
territoriaux
avant de vous faire agir dans lequel
gély on retrouve à nouveau michaël
szames s puisque vous êtes aux côtés de
gérard collomb de l'intérieur se mit à
l'intérieur on a senti dans votre
discours une volonté plus que de
dialogue plus que d'une main tandis
qu'une grande ouverture de porte
vis-à-vis des et du coup l'élu local que
vous êtes à parler puisque l'une y est
les deux ont parlé ensemble le président
de la république comme vous le savez a
annoncé un pacte gironde a et donc
annoncé sa volonté de faire travailler
ensemble
l'état et les collectivités locales ce
n'était pas dans sa bouche qu'un simple
discours c'était une vraie volonté
il s'est exprimé devant les préfets il
ya une dizaine de jours et il l'aura
fait passer ce message il faut
déconcentrer l'état de manière à ce que
vous puissiez discuter avec les
collectivités locales
ça veut dire plus de moyens on a compris
ce matin dans le discours du premier
ministre a donné une enveloppe
budgétaire un peu plus importante
par exemple si on prend un cas concret
pour vous la police de sécurité
quotidienne qui va voir le jour d'ici
peu
elle sera bien financées il n'y aura pas
de contribution de la part des élus
locaux
ah non évidemment il s'agit pas pour
l'état de se défausser sur les
collectivités locales
c'est un jeu que je connais depuis très
longtemps non il s'agit de pas de
prendre notre part et de faire en sorte
simplement d'avoir un travail avec les
maires voit bien aujourd'hui que les
acteurs de la sécurité
c'est évidemment les forces publiques
mais c'est en même temps les polices
municipales que même plus largement pour
organiser les grands événements ce sont
les agents de sécurité et donc dans
quelques temps nous allons lancer une
réflexion avec l'ensemble des acteurs
pour essayer de construire une sécurité
au quotidien
le dialogue a repris est ce que vous
estimez que la taille que l'on traverse
avec ses les élections sénatoriales qui
arrive dès dimanche après ces élections
le dialogue sera finalement plus
qu'apaiser sera redevenu normal je pense
que nous portons le projet d'une france
apaisée
on a vu pendant la campagne
électorale des présidentielles combien
il y avait dans cette france de tensions
de colère et donc nous voulons surmonter
ces tensions et cette colère pour que
dans cinq ans la france soit comme un
certain nombre de nos grandes villes
plus détendu plus joyeuse plus prospère
plus agréable plus propice au bonheur
vous regarderez vous les élections de
dimanche confiant c'est des élections
qui sont être largement déterminée par
les élections municipales et régionales
cantonales passées et donc pour en
marche qui n'existait pas à cette époque
là évidemment il peut pas y avoir de
grandes surprises
je pense que on devrait peut-être
devrait être entre 40 et 50 membres du
groupe et vient elle ne seront pas très
bonnes pour la gauche seront favorables
à la droite mais c'est plutôt le
rétroviseur que l'avenir
merci beaucoup s'est désisté le répondu
en direct à vos questions merci merci à
vous michael retour à ce débat autour
des nouveaux équilibres territoriaux
frédéric gilli on évoquait cette
émergence des métropoles finalement on a
voulu aussi peut-être calquer ce modèle
sur ce qui se fait au niveau européen à
ce que la france qui était prête
est-ce que ça se prête bien justement à
le territoire français en fait je pense
que au delà même de la question
européenne ce et on a calé s'assure une
vision du fonctionnement de l'économie
mondiale dans des rapports de ses débuts
de la banque mondiale il ya quelques
années déjà dix ans que l'économie était
plus performante dans les métropoles et
donc il fallait mettre le paquet sur les
métropoles
le problème c'est que
les métropoles elle concentre de la
richesse été créée autour elles sont pas
créatrices de richesses en tant que tel
et tout seul
elles sont plus productives mais elles
sont plus productifs dans la mesure où
elles sont l'endroit où la richesse est
créée tout autour trouve à se valoriser
et le problème qu'on a notamment quand
on discute quand on regarde quand on
analyse les résultats en termes de
fractures électorales ou de locomotive
et deux wagons
ça donne une idée que il ya les
métropoles qui vont créer de la richesse
il ya tous les territoires autour auquel
il va falloir faire un petit peu
d'aumône et ça ça crée de la fracture et
ça ça crée des vrais problèmes de
cohésion à l'intérieur du pays je pense
que il y avait un très bon signal au
début qui était la notion on était passé
d'une logique d'égalité d' équilibre
territorial à une sonde cohésion ce
qu'attend le paient aujourd'hui moi je
fais les débats publics dans tout le
pays
quotidiennement ce qu'attendent les
français aujourd'hui c'est une logique
de cohésion repenser où chacun trouve sa
place parce que quand on va au fin fond
de dans la banlieue de verdun les gens
ils disent pas je suis coupé de la
mondialisation
ils sont complètement dans la
mondialisation ils sont privés de
l'accès à la mondialisation
et ça ça crée c'est un ver dans le fruit
à la fois pour l'économie du pays et des
métropoles et aussi pour notre modèle
paul est votre réaction michel cantal
dupart vous êtes d'accord est ce qui
vient d'être dit effective notamment
c'était un jour l'accentuer première
chose on est un tout petit territoire
si vous travaillez j'ai la chance de
travailler aux états unis en chine
la taille de la france et c'est une
grande agglomération
bon ça c'est une chose deuxièmement moi
je me rappelle très bien puisqu'on a vu
japon qui vient de s'exprimer
je m'appelle très bien ce qu'il avait
dit en tant qu homme politique maire de
lyon il avait dit au moment du grand
paris il a dit le grand paris
m'intéresse ce le dé la création d'un
grand paris va développer vion et la
développer le développement d'une grande
métropole comme lyon bien évidemment
développe saint-etienne et le
développement de saint-etienne développe
la vallée du gier
c'est ça qu'il faut avoir totalement
tête on est dans une chaîne
et souvent parce qu'on ne fait pas
attention aux maillons certains maillons
se brise et l'exemple de werner est très
très bonne très très bon exemple le
maillot on casse un maillon et à partir
de là on sait pas pourquoi mais le
chapelet part dans tous les sens cette
cohésion des territoires
elle est un petit peu oublié pourtant il
ya un ministère dédié celui de jacques
mézard ancien sénateur qui doit
travailler justement sur ces questions
je crois oui aujourd'hui les discussions
qui se tiennent entre l'état les villes
et les collectivités territoriales sont
très importantes parce qu'il faut
réinventer une nouvelle relation de
confiance justement entre l'état central
et les collectivités territoriales
c'est ce qu'on avait un petit peu oublié
en route dans les lois de la
décentralisation c'est à dire qu'on
n'avait pas mis on n'a pas mis en place
en france qui était pas un état fédéré
donc on n'a pas cette tradition de
dialogue avec les collectivités
territoriales et on n'a pas mis en place
les instances de dialogue alors c'est
paradoxal de le dire dans cette maison
le sénat mais c'est vrai qu'on a besoin
à la fois bien entendu d'un rôle très
important du sénat dans ce dans ce
dialogue mais aussi d'instances de
dialogue
par exemple pour planifier les
investissements on n'a pas cette
instance de dialogue dans un pays comme
la france qui est assez planificateurs
et pourtant nous n'avons pas cet instant
dialogue où on déciderait les grands
infrastructures en commun entre les
régions les métropoles les territoires
ruraux etc
on a besoin d'inventer ces différentes
institutions qui seront les lieux
en fait de constitution d'un pacte entre
l'état et les collectivités
territoriales entre les collectivités
territoriales elle même sur un même
territoire parce que là aussi on a
inventé les conférences territoriales
il n'y a pas longtemps aujourd'hui c'est
pas encore vraiment l'outil qu'on
voudrait pour avoir une véritable
contractualisation entre niveau entre
échelons territoriaux
donc il ya toutes ces
instance de dialogue et de constitution
juste inventé jean baptiste forêt pour
conclure et peut-être pour finir aussi
sur une note positive la commune c'est
par là que viendra le salut finalement
peut-être de cette fracture territoriale
ça va accentuer justement ce rôle ça
reste on le sait notamment le maire un
des acteurs préférés des français
c'est l'un des acteurs préférés des
français ceci étant il a quand même je
veux pas finir sur une note négative
mais il a quand même du mal à trouver a
trouvé son rôle dans le nouvel espace
politique
on voit par exemple l'association des
maires de france qui est vraiment le
porte drapeau de la france de la france
des clochers ya encore peu de temps
il y avait du grain à moudre il y avait
des dotations offrir aux communes il y
avait des éléments de négociation entre
l'état et les communes aujourd'hui en a
plus beaucoup
et du coup on assiste vraiment un
dialogue de sourds entre l'état d'un
côté les communes de l'autre et aussi
d'une certaine façon entre le nouveau
monde et l'ancien monde avec des
associations d'élus qui sont avant tout
dirigée par des gens issus des
républicains et du ps ont du mal à
trouver leurs marques avec avec les
marcheurs qui sont vraiment deux qui ont
un autre logiciel
merci merci jean baptiste forêt à merci
à vous lance en silice merci michel
cantal dupart merci frédéric gillet fait
la force de cette édition merci à vous
de l'avoir suivi à 18h30 on va plus loin
présenté par red et capecchi s'est très
bonne soirée et à demain
[Musique]